cher Nicolas Sarkozy chers amis aussi
Je te l'enverrai lors de la conférence de ton parti
personnellement et au nom du chrétien
Union démocratique de l'Allemagne
meilleures salutations et vous souhaite un
événement réussi
Ils veulent aujourd’hui de nombreuses innovations
décidez pour votre fête
Ci-dessous les règles qui sont les vôtres
Renforcer la démocratie au sein du parti et
par la décentralisation
devrait le rendre plus efficace
aussi ceux de la CDU traversent actuellement
un processus avec lequel nous particulièrement
nos opportunités de participer
les membres veulent encore améliorer
je te souhaite beaucoup de force pour le tien
processus de réforme qui a commencé et je suis heureux
dans l'attente de notre coopération continue
les deux parties